la diabetes mellitus ha flagelado al
mundo desarrollado se estima que 400
millones de personas en todo el mundo
sufren esta enfermedad y se predice un
50% más en el plazo de 20 años sus
primeros síntomas sed y aumento de
grandes volúmenes de orina se
reconocieron ya en 1500 antes de cristo
en egipto aunque el término diabetes que
significa pasar a través lo utilizó por
primera vez en 250 antes de cristo- el
médico griego apolonio de memphis las
diabetes tipo 1 y tipo 2 asociadas
respectivamente con la juventud y la
obesidad se identificaron como
enfermedades separadas por médicos de
india hacia el siglo 5 antes de cristo
pero a pesar de conocerse la enfermedad
el diagnóstico de la diabetes siguió
siendo equivalente a una sentencia de
muerte hasta principios del siglo 20 ya
que no se conocía que la causada lo que
cambió esta situación calamitosa fue la
ayuda del compañero animal de siempre de
la humanidad canis lupus familiarice la
domesticación de lobos grises hace miles
de años los científicos alemanes von
mehring y minkowski demostraron que la
extirpación del páncreas de un perro
provocaba que se desarrollaran todos los
síntomas de la diabetes estableciendo
así el papel central del órgano en la
enfermedad sin embargo el mecanismo
exacto de cómo ocurría fue un misterio
hasta 1920 cuando un joven cirujano
canadiense llamado frederick banting y
su estudiante charles vez desarrollaron
los hallazgos de sus colegas alemanes
trabajando con el profesor mccloud de la
universidad de toronto confirmaron que
el páncreas era responsable de la
regulación de la glucosa en la sangre y
trataron para los perros diabéticos
inyectándoles un extracto de tejidos
pancreáticos en 1922 los investigadores
que trabajaban con el bioquímico james
collie pudieron desarrollar un extracto
de páncreas vacuno para el primer
tratamiento de un niño diabético de 14
años seguido de 6 pacientes más el
proceso de fabricación de este extracto
ahora conocido como insulina finalmente
se entregó a una empresa farmacéutica
que fabrica los diferentes tipos de
insulina inyectable hoy banting y
mccloud recibieron el premio nobel de
medicina en 1923 por su descubrimiento
pero banting decidió compartir su parte
con charles best por su ayuda en los
estudios iniciales que involucraron a
perros
pero aunque la experimentación médica
con animales sigue siendo controvertida
no fue sólo una explotación de perros
para necesidades humanas
los perros desarrollan diabetes a razón
de dos casos por cada mil perros casi la
misma proporción que la de los seres
humanos la mayoría de los casos caninos
son de la diabetes tipo 1 similar al
tipo que desarrollan los niños pequeños
tras la destrucción del páncreas por el
sistema inmunológico los estudios han
demostrado que la enfermedad canina
tiene muchas características similares a
la humana esto ha permitido a su vez
cambiar la situación a los veterinarios
utilizando con éxito la insulina para
tratar la diabetes muchos dueños de
perros se comprometen a controlar la
diabetes con insulina inyectada dos
veces al día
alimentación regulada y análisis de
sangre periódicos utilizando los mismos
monitores de glucosa caseros y si la
insulina de cerdo purificada que se
utiliza comúnmente para perros no
funciona para un perro en particular el
veterinario puede incluso formular
insulina humana cerrando el círculo
después de todo lo que los perros han
hecho por nosotros por siglos incluyendo
su papel en un descubrimiento médico que
ha salvado innumerables vidas humanas
utilizar el mismo conocimiento para
ayudarles es lo mínimo que podemos hacer